foreign
on June 7th 1525 the artist Albrecht
Jura awoke from a nightmare in his sleep
he saw a disturbing vision of the end of
the world being a painter Dura decided
to capture it in a watercolor sketch
below is a brief description of what he
saw I had this Vision in my sleep and
saw how many Great Waters fell from
heaven the first struck the ground about
four miles away from me enormous noise
and splashing that it drowned the entire
Countryside dura's vision of the
Apocalypse is one of the earliest
artistic representations of a dream his
fears of a world-ending flood
reminiscent that described in the Book
of Genesis had entered his subconscious
and resurfaced as a nightmare for
Millennia dreams have inspired artists
to delve into their own minds and bring
forth bizarre images from their
subconscious from depictions of surreal
dream stains to Impossible and at times
frightening monsters welcome to the
enigmatic world of surreal art where the
unconscious mind demands to be drawn
every night while we sleep something
strange happens our eyes may be closed
but we are still able to see we are
dreaming and despite this phase of our
sleep lasting roughly two hours per
night when we awake we often don't
remember a thing we're not the only
species that can dream it's been
observed in other intelligent mammals
but we are unique in our ability to
record and depict these Visions through
art for the Aboriginal people of
Australia dreams play a central role in
their beliefs and Customs using natural
rust-colored pigments they illustrate
encounters had with Spirits ancestors
and animals these artworks are used to
tell legends about our world these
stories known as the dream time are
captured in a distinctive artistic style
characterized by dotted painting and use
of earthy tones as the oldest continuous
culture on Earth the average original
Australians have passed down these tales
and techniques for Millennia and quite
possibly preserved the oldest unbroken
artistic tradition in the world a
tradition rooted in dreaming references
to visions and their meanings appear in
some of the earliest forms of human
writing since ancient times dreams were
believed to be a journey the soul goes
on each night acting as a bridge for the
spirit world and the physical one to the
ancient Egyptians these nighttime
voyages were a chance to see reality
more clearly their word for dream reset
means Awakening it's no surprise that
dreams feature heavily in the Bible a
book full of visions of the Divine and
glimpses into the cosmic unknown one
popular story is the dream of Jacob's
Ladder from The Book of Genesis in which
the biblical patriarch sees a ladder of
angels moving to and from Heaven this
scene is depicted in many works of of
religious art but perhaps my favorite is
the one by Giuseppe de Ribera at first
glance it may appear simple plain even
just a sleeping man right but if you
look closer you can see wispy figures
resembling Angels traveling up the light
it captures the ephemeral nature of our
dreams blink and you'll miss it but
where there are dreams there are also
nightmares creatures from the
unconscious world are not always
friendly you can find all sorts of
nightmarish paintings from early
Christian art many I've explored in more
detail on the channel from the
disturbing paintings of Hieronymus Bosch
to the strange selection of demon
doodles from 1565. these early forms of
Fantastical art include creatures
plucked from a dark imagination for a
long time it was believed that bad
dreams themselves were caused by
monsters in German and Slavic folklore
the mayor was a creature that sat on the
body during sleep causing the victim to
suffer frightening dreams or nightmares
the feeling of having a heavy demon
sitting on your chest is based on the
experience of sleep paralysis those rare
moments when your mind wakes up before
your body they are often accompanied by
unnerving visual hallucinations I guess
you could say that the mare is the
original sleep paralysis demon while
medieval Europeans were having
nightmares about the end of the world in
the Far East there has long been a
tradition of Dreams bringing good luck
according to Japanese mythology if you
dream of an eagle Mount Fuji and an
eggplant on the first night of the year
you will have good fortune this strange
combination may not seem to have much in
common but you can find them together
throughout Japanese wood block images at
the end of the 19th century French
artist odilon redon became inspired by
Japanese art and also painted the
symbols he found in his dreams some of
his Works were based on Greek mythology
like the Cyclops in which the giant
polyphemus peers over the brow of a hill
other paintings are less figurative
simply impressions of color and tone
that create these vague shapes and
ghostly apparitions for his paintings
redone earned the nickname The Prince of
Dreams here are a few more
[Music]
redon didn't like it when people
attempted to analyze his paintings he
preferred for viewers to Simply
experience them and see what emotions
they stirred
[Music]
what this artist didn't know is that he
was about to inspire a movement one that
believed that painting the unconscious
could reveal hidden secrets of our
psyche things were about to get surreal
in the year 1900 the renowned
psychoanalyst Sigmund Freud remarked
that the interpretation of Dreams is the
Royal Road to the unconscious he
believed that dreams contain symbols
that can unlock our deepest desires
fears and hopes perhaps a box of jewels
represents greed a skull a fear of death
or a mask embarrassment he used these
symbols to help understand the minds of
his patients if the mind can reveal
itself through dreams what if it could
reveal itself through ART after all art
has long been used as a way to express
one's inner feelings consider one of the
world's most famous paintings the Scream
by Edvard monk the agonized face of the
figure in the middle has been seen as
the Vivid expression of anxiety at the
upper left corner there is a small
pencil inscription could only have been
painted by a Madman whether or not this
was written by the Norwegian artist is
still uncertain in the 1920s a group of
French artists were heavily inspired by
Freud's theories on dreams and how they
may reveal the unconscious mind to
unlock their own psyche they got to work
and let their imaginations run wild the
results were paintings based on strange
nonsensical subjects and imaginative
Landscapes their paintings were Beyond
reality or in French surrealism one of
the most famous painters of this era was
the Spanish artist Salvador Dali he and
his fabulous mustache created some of
the world's most iconic surrealist
paintings like the Persistence of memory
a landscape featuring melting clocks the
closer you look The Stranger it gets
like the ants swarming around a
stopwatch and something that looks like
a closed eye in the center and then
there's the solitary egg in the distance
what these images tell us about Dali
subconscious are still debated Dali was
a vivid dreamer and so many of his
paintings captured what he saw whilst
asleep like the descriptively named
dream caused by the flight of a bee
around a pomegranate a second before
waking there's a lot going on here
tigers with guns jumping out of a giant
fish in the chaos and confusion you'll
be forgiven for overlooking this
elephant in the background an elephant
with long spindly legs there are so many
absurd painters and paintings in the
surrealist movement from the
metaphysical Landscapes of the chicharo
to the comical portraits by Magritte
highlights include the treachery of
images a painting with the caption this
is not a pipe ah I see what you did
there
to loosen up their minds the surrealists
use the technique they called automatic
drawing which involved moving the pen
freely across the page
this technique sounds suspiciously like
scribbling to me something that's been
around for a while I guess automatic
drawing sounds more artistic for the
surrealist artists the aim of these
paintings was to capture a snapshot of
the unconscious what exactly they
captured is still unclear but perhaps
that's the point what we're left with
are these absurd and wonderful paintings
plucked from the imagination
foreign
has been seen as the high point of
imaginative art but as we have seen
drawing the unconscious has had a long
history the surrealist painters are a
continuation of what came before in the
Renaissance we see examples of
experimental and abstract art such as a
book from 1568 made up of geometric
shapes these images may not have had
specific meanings but served as studies
in drawing perspective they remind me of
the work of M.C Escher an artist famous
for his spirally illogical stairways
other artists took the concept of
Illusions even further creating
paintings with hidden faces can you see
the face in this landscape what about
this one the moment you see it you can't
unsee it one artist particularly fond of
Illusions like this was Giuseppe
arkhambaldo all the way back in the 16th
century this artist created portraits of
a man made of fruit a woman made of
vegetables or a librarian made up
entirely of books are kimbaldo made many
more of these mind-bending paintings a
gallery of strange fruity faces from
centuries past images like these
stimulate our unconscious mind to work
in another way to see things that are
not really there the human brain has a
natural bias to see faces in objects a
phenomenon known as paredolia this is
why some cars seem to have faces houses
too even without thinking our busy minds
are creating little pieces of art all
the time and this brings us to the
future of unconscious art so far we have
seen art made by humans something with a
Consciousness but what about something
that does not have a Consciousness at
all deep dream is an artificial
intelligence program that generates
unusual works of art by finding faces in
images here's the Mona Lisa with an
algorithm trained to find dogs
the results are completely bizarre
psychedelic even and it's another
example of paradolia this time it isn't
a human seeing faces it's a machine you
can see how it works over a series of
images you start with a picture of
jellyfish run it through deep dream and
you get this
do it a second time and the whole thing
goes into creative overdrive some of
these programs are available to the
public like Dali I've made some images
of my own can you guess the prompt I
used just like its namesake the
surrealist artist Salvador Dali Dali is
an attempt at creating unconscious art
but in the case of the AI there is no
consciousness at all with the arrival of
artificial intelligence our definitions
of creativity are starting to be
challenged although AI is still in its
infancy and still requires human input
to make these artworks it is possible
that one day they will be able to create
images for themselves out of their
imagination maybe one day an AI artist
will have a bad dream and decide to
paint what they saw just like a human
artist did 500 years ago
hey thanks for watching I really hope
you enjoyed this one if you like this
video and want to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way in case you don't know
I've made an investigative series The
Interruption available to listen
wherever you get your podcasts oh and do
check out the Channel's merch over at
crowdmade we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies links are in the description
down below anyway I look forward to
seeing you next time
goodbye